can your professional y be different
from your personal y can your can your
professional y change based on your role
ah thank you for asking this question
thank you for asking this question
you only have one y there is no such
thing as a personal y and a professional
Y you are who you are and the reason
your friends love you is the exact same
reason your colleagues and your
customers and your clients love you it's
because of you and if you're acting
differently in one of those two places
than in one of those two places you're
lying
there's only one Y and the opportunities
to bring your Y to life personally
remember it's not about what you do so
my Y is to inspire people so how do I
show up as a friend to inspire people
how do I show up as a as a as a
colleague to inspire people I'm gonna
say different things but ultimately I
have to bring my Y to life in different
products those products our friend might
those products our leader those products
our colleague those predix or brother
and son and uncle and all of these
places these are different products
these are different things that I do
that I have to bring my Y to life so you
only have one y and your Y never changes
your whole life regardless of the role
you play the opportunity your life
affords you is is to bring your is all
the choices you can make to bring your Y
to life so the question is is what
you're doing and why you're doing it
consistent because only when why how and
what are in perfect balance do we know
who you are people that people tell me
all that for years people's I forgot the
who know I didn't who is the sum total
of Y how and what when you know what you
believe and you follow your values and
what you do reflects what you believe in
your values then we know who you are if
those things are out of order or they or
you violate those things people say it's
like I don't know who you are anymore
you have one why your Y never changes
just like a company our personal wise an
origin story it's where we come from
it's who we are it's how we were raised
and the rest of our lives
are opportunities to live in balance or
not
[Music]